[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish today we
Circle The Globe for a taste of
international cuisine with layovers in
London for Indian food and Philadelphia
for Thai Dishes first we're heading to
Colombia not the country the oldest
restaurant in Florida serving meals with
Cuban Spanish Sicilian and even a bit of
German influences here's Jeff glor
foreign
[Music]
that keeps people coming back
what's the story of a family that
immigrated from Cuba and from Spain with
a dream
the dream began just after the turn of
the last century Cuban immigrants
casimiro Hernandez was looking to fill
the bellies of workers going back and
forth to Cigar factories in Tampa Bay's
historic Ybor City
during the Great Depression his son
built the first air-conditioned dining
room in Tampa in the 50s and 60s when
Ebor city was dying Colombia kept it
alive
post-war the business expanded to
Sarasota to the South and in the 1980s
Saint Augustine to the east led by
Richard gunsmartz fourth generation at
Columbia and now his daughter Andrea
fifth we actually lived next door to one
another I didn't know that yeah we don't
get enough of each other at work so we
have to live next door we should come
over at five in the morning we'll start
talking and we'll go on a walk and at
night time we'll go back and forth
Andrea gonsmart started working at
Columbia at age 10. Richard says he's
been thinking about running a restaurant
since he was three and a half he still
does from the moment he wakes up not too
long after the crack of midnight I love
that that moment you know from 1 30 or 3
in the morning 1 30 1 30 in the morning
yeah it's a good time to wake up and
that's when you're looking at the
industry planning out and reading what's
happening in the world and the industry
and understand to predict what's going
to take place be prepared or they never
get tired of that God that's what I live
for he eats sleeps and breathes the
restaurant business
it's all I know
Richard refers to himself not as
president or CEO of Colombia but
caretaker he's also added a sicilian
restaurant in Ybor City and now operates
a total of 14 restaurants under six
Brands he's still pushing and opening
new restaurants he's an animal
he claims he's trying to pass the Baton
but he's running too fast for me did you
tell him to calm down or do you just let
let him let the let him go I ride the
wave I love it I'm always right behind
him on all of his crazy ideas there's a
lot to get done
among Colombia's Staples a Cuban
sandwich that they proudly Proclaim
predates anything served in the nation's
most populous Cuban Locale Miami the
most important part of beginning a Cuban
sandwich is starting with great Cuban
bread it is served to Richards exacting
instructions my father says it's
important that you go in this exact
order otherwise when it hits your palate
it's not going to taste the same so
we're going to start with the ham okay
and each of these layers symbolize the
people who came to Ybor City in the turn
of the century so this represents the
Spaniards that came obviously the Cuban
bread represents the Cuban yes
but our next player is also going to
represent the Cubans
it's the moho married roast pork there's
a ritual to it I mean it's it's almost
therapeutic yeah we use only the salami
imported from Italy that's got the
Peppercorns in it and this represents
the Sicilians who came to Ybor City and
now we're going on to the Swiss cheese
which I always say this almost
represents Ybor City because it was
truly The Melting Pot of all of these
different cultures coming together so
when you put it on the press or if you
don't put it on the Press
it tops it all and marries them all
together it's hard to find a more
inclusive dish yeah right
the Columbia Cuban is topped off with a
single thin layer of mustard a nod to
Germany and always exactly two pickles
follow the simple recipe and you get
something exceptional
or you just mess it up from the start
did I do it oh shoot hello now you've
got an upside down Cuban I do
it's a special sort of Cuban like my
it's an upside I'm Cuban
the Cuban sandwich preparation was just
a Prelude to The Wider spread each one
of these dishes you could write a book
on the history behind it almost yes our
table included Colombia's legendary
1905. a julienne style salad always
prepared tableside Pompano in papayote
Seafood baked in a parchment crust Poyo
Manchego crab croquettes and in the
middle of it all the complete Cubana the
complete Cuban it tells you a taste of
what I remember Cuba the roast pork
marinade the mohom the bulichi which is
the Iran with the trees and Engraving
the Empanada fried plantains Yucca which
is a root with a garlic and the black
beans and rice with the onions the black
beans are the way we did totally
vegetarian the paye valenciana our rice
comes from Murcia from the south it's
the way I would have had it and when I
visit Spain for desserts flan along with
an irresistible white chocolate bread
pudding
just so some of the food and family that
have kept people coming back for more
than 117 years
[Music]
what do you think your dad would think
of how you've taken care of the
restaurant and what you've turned it
into my father had a lot of dreams I
have a picture of him when he was a
little boy he was a violinist and he
didn't get to do many of the things he
wanted to
I fulfilled every dream he ever had
and so I feel my dad will be very proud
[Music]
after the break we visit Indian royalty
running a groundbreaking Kitchen in the
UK this is the dish
[Music]
now we head across the pond to visit an
award-winning London restaurant serving
authentic Indian Cuisine MTS tyab sat
down with one of Britain's most
prominent female figures in food and
dining who add spice to everything she
does
foreign
Khan knows how to command a kitchen yeah
it's perfect it's perfect
but it's not the life the chef and
social justice activists saw for herself
growing up in Calcutta as the second
daughter born into an Indian royal
family this princess yes princess can
not only handle the heat okay two
doubles first okay okay Asha give me one
haleem she also leads a team of cooks
unlike anywhere else all women of color
and most like her
or second daughters I'm a second order
and you know what does that mean in your
culture disaster because you're not the
boy everybody wanted tell us about your
kitchen so it's an all-female kitchen
which is very unusual you will never
find a restaurant anywhere in the world
cooking you know South Asian food with
an all-female kitchen I would never have
even sat down on a table and with these
women in India because of the Class cast
religious differences between people but
today they are like my own family and
for them this is liberation
it's set them free
for Khan learning how to cook the food
she grew up eating as a child in eastern
India also set her free after getting
married in 1991 and moving to England
she in her own words didn't even know
how to boil an egg and egged for the
flavors of home we don't realize how it
is part of who we are the air we breathe
part of you know our soul I I really
understood this when I had an arranged
marriage I moved to Cambridge
and I was living with a stranger who I
was trying to make friends with
and then you know the ache of not eating
your own food was overwhelming after
studying for a PhD in British
constitutional law Khan returned to
India to learn how to recreate the
tastes of her childhood back in Britain
her love of the complex Cuisine
blossomed into a new life first hosting
supper parties for strangers at her home
then opening a restaurant The Darjeeling
Express publishing a renowned cookbook
and now a major expansion moving her
wildly popular Eatery to London's
historic Covent Garden
but you have to start testing stuff
because I'm I I know that I've been
speaking to you without so you you can
be you can choose whatever you want to
start off with right well I want to
start with what's in front of me here
this is so this is the uh Bach foreign
try a bit uh and it's uh very Bengali
okay and it gives it it's red Q it's
it's tomato it's really the sourness
that comes through yes yeah
followed by the heat yeah and and this
is how you have to spice you spice the
layers Curry is Britain's most popular
food
but the often creamy dishes served with
thick Breads in restaurants around the
country are a far cry from the authentic
Indian dining experience Khan wants her
customers to enjoy like this beetroot
raita an electrocute yogurt to soothe
the palate yes bubblegum color and what
is nice about this is that it has only
one Spice in it which is roasted and put
in I won't put you on the spot and ask
you to identify it but it's
okay
[Laughter]
your mom did a good job raising you so
that is that the Biryani wow taste it
because it's very very gentle but it's
the classic Calcutta Biryani that Khan
is most renowned for Royal rice dish
cooked in layers for several hours her
carrot halva is also work intensive do
that the dessert is made with milk sugar
and spices that require several hours of
near constant stirring
so it's just and you can taste that
this tastes like my childhood oh
it really I mean I'm having a moment
here because
my mother would make this
part of Khan's mission is for her
customers to have a more complete
understanding of South Asian Cuisine I
mean I always find it very hard when
people come to my restaurant and say can
I have none and I said I don't even know
how to make it and then look at yourself
aren't you Indian I was thinking like
most Indians would not know how to make
it or eat it yeah they don't have it at
home no and also the other things
everyone thinks you have a Tandoor in
your house your house will catch fire
the only Flames Khan wants to Fan give
the Chutney on the sides huh horror of
understanding
and through her food she hopes her table
will bring people who might not
otherwise come together
I've had such an extraordinary time
eating your food
what do you want people to feel when
they eat your food
I want them
to get up from the stable not hating
people who look like me because it's
about breaking bread together you eat my
food you understand me a bit next time
you're on the Underground you sit next
to a woman maybe her coat smells of
masala
look at her in the eye don't hate us
don't label us
you've opened this extraordinary
restaurant in an extraordinary time in
our life what do you want people to
experience when you walk through these
doors I want them to feel this is a
homecoming it doesn't you don't need to
be selfish you don't need anything but
for all of us who have not seen family
who've been cut off who have been so you
know not able to live our normal life I
want this restaurant to be your Refuge
come here put your burden down and eat
foreign
the City of Brotherly Love is way more
than Cheesesteaks in Philadelphia we
actually found one of the best Thai
restaurants in the country where they
look Beyond typical dishes like Pad Thai
for a more refined fine dining approach
here's our Jeff Gore
this looks incredible yeah the look is
everything
and I mean that's the first impression
when you see it is build your appetite
where do we start we start from the
appetizer knock soon Turan and kick
things off with what might be the most
colorful dish we've ever seen including
tapioca dumplings with a mushroom sweet
radish and peanut filling and flower
shaped dumplings with chicken and sweet
radish inside it's a bird dumpling it's
a bird it's a bird my name is mean bird
so this is my dumpling it takes hours to
make these completely by hand but it's
well worth it hmm
so fresh my food is built around memory
of my childhood so my grandmother she
always loved to cook the little
appetizer for me when she came I came
back from school since renin's
grandmother never shared any of those
old recipes so she relies on the
memories of the taste and smells she
experienced growing up in Thailand so
this dish is come from the old capital
of Thailand in ayutaya that's very close
to Bangkok that includes this spicy and
sour lemongrass soup with barramundi
mushrooms and these jumbo River prawns
okay so I break the head off you break
the head off then you will find the part
in the head is tamales that's like the
brain or the fatty part you can scrape
it back into the bowl
it's like squeezing out the best
condiment ever exactly and they're so
creamy it's at a very good flavor and
good consistency into the broth some
people think you eat Thai food with
chopsticks you don't no we don't since
Uranus take on traditional Thai Dishes
are a unique blend of Buddhist culture
Indian style curries and crucially South
American chilies originally brought to
the region by Portuguese missionaries in
the late 1600s their intensity is
matched only by centuranin's personality
heat is something that Thai Dishes are
famous for and you're famous for not
backing off on that heat you don't make
less spicy dishes no I never back off
from anything not just only food
I like that
for more than 20 years since Iranian
worked as a flight attendant for Kuwait
Airways then Thai Airways have you had a
fresh River prime before no I don't
think so she was retired for nine years
before opening Kalaya in Philadelphia in
2019. one thing that I think sometimes
intimidates people about Thai food
especially really authentic Thai food
like this is that it's not it's not
simple it's it's complicated you know
that's how you could look at it but the
other way that you could look at it is
like this is the way of life this is the
culture well that's one of the things I
love about your cooking is that you
don't some people try to americanize
their food and you don't you Embrace
where you came from because I think you
know when when I moved to America I I
learned how to eat cheeseburger or
mac and cheese and I never asked to put
Daniel ground chili on my burger or mac
and cheese so maybe it's time for people
to learn how to eat the right curries
without asking for me to tone it down or
add you know carrot or celery or
whatever in my curries because that's
not not the right thing to do after the
river prawn soup we moved to a duck
salad with kefir leaves and dried
chilies then this delicious crab fried
rice with scallion and egg what is in
this this is so good the egg and pickle
mustard green okay that's very simple
that's my mother's cooking she will cook
all vegetables with eggs they go with
everything this goes with everything
next the Colossal crab Curry served in a
house-made velvety curry powder sauce
maybe our favorite I'm glad I'm making
somebody very happy this morning you are
velvety is a good word for it it is it's
a great texture yes what make it
different is we use Chinese salaries
that you just had to buy into it and the
flavor of Chinese celery cut with the
curry powders so the the first bite I
had it didn't have the Chinese celery in
it no and the second one it did and it
makes all the difference yes that was
followed by steam bronzino with a lime
and a Thai Chili broth Phuket style crab
meat curry served with rice noodles
cucumber cabbage and long beans there
aren't many places in America where you
can get this
without me and my staff no because we're
not going to be there so only at color
yeah
I love it all right next you ready yeah
I'm ready so you're gonna be a little
bit more adventurous yeah sure okay
stinky beans with toasted ground chicken
curry and shrimp paste oh stinky Bean
yes so my wife calls me
[Laughter]
I call homesick at the
end so I created more dishes that could
bring me closer to home
and so what is the stinky Bean this is
the bean this is stinky Bean is the kai
of fruit that we use widely in southern
cooking it's available in rainy season
this is a very unique flavor
is really good for your body
we finished with coconut rice chicken
curry and cabbage there is one prominent
Thai Dish you will not find on this
table and that you will not find soon to
run and serving in her restaurants you
don't have Pad Thai on your menu we do
on take out not in the dining room and
people ask for it and you say what I
smile
[Laughter]
I smile a lot because I want my
restaurant to be Thai fight dining
where do you hope you can take Thai food
moving forward
what I would like to take Thai food
forward is the perception that Thai food
or ethnic food should be inexpensive we
should move past that you've convinced
me
I did yes
maybe the big giant shrimp convince you
not me
coming up we go inside a family run
restaurant based on Afghan recipes
dating back Generations we're going to
take you there next on the dish
[Music]
there are several successful Afghan
restaurants around our nation's capital
where they use recipes passed down from
generations of mothers to daughters Jan
Crawford introduces us to a family with
a powerful message about food and
tradition
when Sophia mesurer is making her famous
leak and scallion dumplings she smiles I
just love it because it reminds me of my
childhood it's my all-time favorite dish
the childhood that began in Afghanistan
before her family fled to the United
States after the Soviet invasion when
the country was a Cosmopolitan
celebration of cultures my mother when
she would make this dish my favorite
part was to do this oh really yes sit
around the dining room table and we
would stuff the wrappers the delicate
leak and scallion dumplings are just one
of the classic dishes featured in Sophia
and husband Omar's Washington DC area
Afghan restaurants which they started as
a way to share their country's
sophisticated Cuisine every African
restaurant you would go to is this Kebab
Kebab kebab which is not the tradition
it's not traditional there's so much
more there's so much more to Afghan food
food influenced by the many cultures
that formed Afghanistan food that's
going to be coming from Central Asia you
know from China India the Persians so
it's a mixture of of everything this
food is like Afghanistan a combination
of cultures and different ethnicities
and backgrounds all coming together in
like a beautiful Harmony which country
that you can go to or which nation you
could go to that you could get a rice
dish that's gonna have raisins in there
that's going to have carrots in there
that's going to have almonds walnuts
meat pistachios
today Afghanistan is anything but
harmonious
seeing it return to Taliban control LED
them as rulers to make a statement last
fall that went well beyond food
Omar decided to step back from the
operations and put the women his wife's
sister and his two oldest daughters in
charge I said listen the only way to do
a change or to make a statement is you
have to from inside to do something not
through words not through anything but
through action
what was the statement that you were
trying to make them women can do
anything oldest daughter Talia is the
new manager of Bistro aracasia running
all the restaurants day-to-day
operations Oman is manager and training
at the McLean location sometimes people
ask me for the manager and I'm like well
I am the manager what does it mean to
you to kind of be a part of this
statement that you're making oh it makes
me feel good that they think that I can
manage a restaurant and run a restaurant
I want to be CEO of the restaurants and
just learn how to do everything
the critically acclaimed restaurants
that women now in charge continue to
expand locations with plans to open a
fourth restaurant in the area they
attribute their success to the customers
and the recipes that span Generations
from one mother to the next I mean I
learned this from my mother so that's
how she made it that's how I made it and
that's how I'm teaching
others to make it and now passing again
to the next what is your dream for your
your daughters
as they grow up to know who they are
that's all I just want them to to to
know that they could do anything they
want to do they can run a business they
can be a CEO better better well what's
your dream for their futures for them to
you know be confident believe in
themselves
kind human beings you know it's just
also it's not just about them it's about
everyone and for all those other girls
needing to hear you can do it
foreign
like these and live coverage of breaking
news 24 7 stream us right here on CBS
News I'm Dana Jacobson we'll see you
next time for another helping of the
dish
[Music]